[Musique]
le président de la république en appelle
à l'unité dans un message posté sur
twitter il réitère sa confiance aux
français les heures que nous vivons sont
cruciales faisons tout pour freiner
l'épidémie ensemble at il écrit en ce
dernier samedi de soldes ultime achats
pour ses clients dans ce grand magasin
parisien
une pièce d'identité est désormais il
faut présenter un test pcr négatif d'au
moins 72 heures aux frontières pour
rentrer en france depuis un pays de
l'union européenne sauf pour les
travailleurs transfrontaliers
tous les commerces non alimentaires en
france de plus de 20 mille mètres carrés
sont désormais fermés jusqu'à nouvel
ordre
les luttes en cours dans le sur les
chaînes les différentes chaînes que
samedi
al'annonce de la veille du premier
ministre avait fait une ruée dans les
centres commerciaux je sais pas si les
gestes barrières étaient respectés en
tout cas dans les images que j'ai vues
il y avait beaucoup de monde
j'aurais aimé que le gouvernement que ce
soit le premier ministre ou l'oracle
qu'on attend le dimanche soir puis
finalement l'a pas eue qui nous explique
et bien pour l'hiver prochain pour les
semaines qui viennent on va se donner
les moyens d'augmenter les livres
animations et on laisse les sera ouvert
pour cet été pour l'hiver prochain
bien être conscient que si on confine
pas et que ça continue comme ça et au
rythme où ça va ben on va devoir faire
des choix on va rentrer dans une
médecine
tôt ou tard
mode médecine de catastrophe dans le jdd
ce matin le ministre de la santé
justifie pourtant le choix de ne par
confiner le pays l'incidence c'est à
dire le nombre de nouveaux cas
quotidiens a peu augmenté depuis quatre
jours plusieurs semaines après la
généralisation du couvre-feu
ça peut signifier que son effet maximal
se fait sentir 49% des chefs
d'entreprise aujourd'hui son inquiet se
disent même éventuellement prêts sont
incapables de supporter un troisième
confinement la moindre semaine le
moindre jour de confinement on peut
éviter aux français il faut qu'on prenne
est-ce qu'on a encore la possibilité
d'éditer un confinement dont on connaît
l'impact pour les français en termes
économiques en terme de santé mentale en
terme psychologique et la réponse est
oui j'appelle tous les amis
restaurateurs à ne pas ouvrir pour la
bonne et simple raison que si vous le
faites peut-être lent click and collect
sur le domaine public d'accord pourquoi
parce que derrière la prends des amendes
énormes des fermetures administratives
énorme sauf que moi j'irai jusqu'au bout
je veux bien servir d'exemple à vous
ouvrez bien sûr qu'on ouvre les français
doivent savoir qu après 18 heures ils
ont beaucoup de chance de se faire
contrôler et donc verbaliser et y aurait
eu 65 mille contrôles qui ont été
effectués pour quasiment 6000
verbalisation puis bon ben on en train
de tout ce que l'affairé on ne prescrit
un peu rouillé après quatre mois de
fermeture il ouvrira demain illégalement
son établissement sur la pause déjeuner
une action symbolique pour demander un
changement de méthode
comment voulez vous que les français
adhèrent un projet collectif quand ils
ont le sentiment qu'on est tout le temps
en retard en retard sur les masques en
retard sur les tests en retard sur le
vaccin
maintenant peut-être en retard c'est le
président gilbert dû s'exprimer alors
mais le président s'il pense que ce qui
se dit est juste et bien qu'ils
s'engagent et qui viennent expliquer aux
français je sais pas ce qu'est ce que le
président a à a fait chi ou à fait ça
c'est une décision personnelle c'est
exactement comme ça que ça se passe
oui mais en réalité ça se pose
certainement comme ça mais ce jour des
gens qui prennent des décisions sur des
dossiers et sur des dossier étayé et je
trouve qu'on devrait absolument à voir
tout cela on essaye d'être transparent
de dire aux français dans les yeux
quelle est la situation
on donne toutes les données tout est en
open data tout est disponible et on leur
dit quelles sont les pistes
on regarde pour les protéger second
point oui une fois n'est pas coutume que
je vais donner c'est qu'il n'a pas suivi
les injonctions comminatoire des experts
et quand le voulait berlin dit qu'on les
experts médicaux qui sont sortis et de
certains ministres en disant dès demain
nous allons confiné préparez-vous etc
et là il s'est rebiffé d'une certaine
façon il ya parfois c'est vrai un peu un
côté au concours lépine de savants qui
sortent des propositions voilà nous on
essaye d'être clair et de ne pas
infantiliser justin